so we were at CES this year we saw a
bunch of brand new cameras serve
high-end enthusiast cameras yeah a lot
of people are kind of moving up from the
sort of smartphone cameras smartphones
actually have pretty good lenses on them
these days you're taking pretty good
pictures and I and personally I believe
that Instagram is getting people more
interested in photography so people are
moving up to the gateway drug it's a
gateway yeah so people are moving up to
like like like Fugees x100 like cameras
like that like not quite a DSLR but
something to me like a medium-sized like
professional quality camera that was
that was a good one we saw there yes
last two months ago now Jesus been that
long feels like yesterday another one
that we saw there which actually came
out of the fall but it's just now making
its way to the market is this one this
is the new sony rx1 it's extremely
expensive i think its twenty eight
hundred dollars and it has fixed lens it
doesn't zoom it shoots video but the
nice thing about it is that it has a
full-frame 35-millimeter sensor yeah so
it's like you know people always say as
good as a DSLR as good as a DSLR so this
capture is the same amount of
information you know in a in a digital
sensor that you can capture with a film
camera a traditional SLR camera which
gives you a lot more information to work
with and results in better images and
though I mean the whole this type of
camera didn't really exist a few years
ago yeah yeah it was you you had to have
it was either DSLR or kind of a kind of
crappy point-and-shoots that you could
buy for a couple hundred bucks so I
think I think it's kind of great that
people are getting away from these
crappy 200 all-important you it's
getting into really nice cameras at 600
800 a thousand yeah 2,800 you mean again
these really nice no something's really
cool they're giving you like really nice
prime lenses so these you know you're
not getting this kind of you know junkie
lenses that you're found on the point
you and I'm actually happy that
smartphones are kind of getting rid of
the pointe shoes because those were just
they were served like they were a
stopgap mean they were way in they were
there in the disc camera yeah this is a
reverent the thing were the 110 one
cameras the things you got you into take
a little tog raphy and then you wanted
more so that you that that gap used to
be filled by point shoots and now it's
sort of filled by the phone and now you
know people who are interested can take
it as far as they want what it's very
cool i like what school that this is
that it has a shoe adapter for an
optical yeah so it has a hot shoe so
there's no viewfinder on it we should
mention that but you know you can you
can get a viewfinder has a pop-up flash
you can also attach other flashes to it
it's a really amazing camera we just got
a yesterday we've been playing with it
you know pretty much non-stop over the
last 24 hours and we're going to review
it and you can read the review on wired
later on a march but for now I can tell
you that the sony rx1 is definitely
worth the twenty eight hundred dollars
you will pay to own one what do you
think um I have to play with it okay he
doesn't play with the emissary with a
gorgeous i love it i don't want to give
it back um something else have we been
looking at that we don't want to give
back our these these awesome headphones
from v-moda m100 s the cross fades be
done the chance to test these out i
haven't had a chance trust those out
either I don't get your keeping
everything from me I'm a total gear hog
it's true but you know it's kind of my
job I'm supposed to supposed to test
everything supposed to touch everything
to tell you people about it I can tell
you these are awesome I've been wearing
these every day for the last three weeks
and v-moda is a company that was founded
by a DJ and so they're kind of DJ
centric headphones but this is sort of
their audio file high-end entry into the
headphone market now you and I both
swear by the studio headphones like the
audio technica ath m 50s which I like a
little natural tuning yeah so like a lot
of Labor yeah not I don't need a lot of
bass i mean i can i can adjust that i
want listen to upset listen to a lot of
different types of music I don't just
listen to hip-hop it or just just in the
rock I listen to hip-hop what about what
about jazz rock but that kind of that
that kind of goes against like the the
way that headphones are tuned now yeah
everybody wants more bass or more
clarity which you know can kind
gunk up the music yeah maybe he's a
little bit better for for you know
walking around if you're super into
hip-hop I mean the beats by anybody dre
whoever yeah those are you know there's
a really great headphone descents
headphones yeah but if you want listen
to muse probably what those probably
aren't going to work so hot so these I
could tell you sit somewhere in between
they're very very close to studio
monitors style headphone so they're dry
but they do have a little bit of a bump
in the base and do have a little bit of
Roloffs in the high end so they're not
harsh and the nice thing about it is
that you get like a big full natural
sound but you can wear them all day with
our ears getting the sort of fatigue
from all the symbol hits and the S is
the sibilance and this and also it makes
your shitty mp3 sound better too oh cool
yeah because it eliminates that sort of
high-end crunch that you get oh that's
nice yeah from highly compressed music
this product these are three hundred
dollars and they're available now
they're just all so just make either way
out into the marketplace so you can buy
them online right now I don't know where
you get retail but i'm going to be
reviewing them and you can read that
review also coming up in the coming
weeks on wired will have a different
crew next week because some of us will
be in South by Southwest oh you're being
talked i will i'll be in austin but so
Rob you probably hear and what are you
gonna show us next week I don't know
cheers here just tears and anger Iran
shares an irrational anger uh so I keep
up to date with all the latest news of
the gadget lab and we'll see you next
week